hey out of old games I play I did not
think I would make part two out of this
one I need to check in with my woman
your wife
that she is a CA a tiger rose yeah she
won Sam and she I know she wants [ __ ]
wants chocolate I have this rose
[Music]
hey oh I got a message oh I love my
boobs in this pic of all the pics of me
out there on their net I think this one
is my favorite smiley face
this is the greatest game of all time
pushes on all my Lola um have a bag of
Lola but just some bagels here I have
some tennis balls that worked what's the
size of your taste you really have to
know that I win more than you he's
wearing a towel oh damn it
it's [ __ ] this game is hard as hell
oh here we go here we go stop ah yes
we're almost at rest we're almost there
come on come on come on yeah what a
shame that day I saw I get money for
going out on a date with her let's focus
on our sugar mommy hello hello what's
the end game with this game Jesus Christ
what does she like romance right oh yeah
those are really effective try take all
my affection girl
while we can do it price so my wife
don't leave me my life do you love
cranny crash do you love any more girls
of course did you love car everyone
that's any move at least we've got money
what does she expect Jesus they put so
much on me
what about my feeling hi Daddy
yeah okay she called me daddy
that's it sad that I'm playing this game
instead of just going up and hanging out
with my own girlfriend
alright let's state at the beach okay of
course just hanging out at beach again
no big deal I mean now have some cotton
candy
come on I need one successful day one
running out of lock here
[Music]
[Music]
I'm I'm a dishonor to my family I can
you can get this girl this is the
hardest game I play in my life and now
I'm sinking sinking to rise no more I
used to use my racquet a lot never for
tennis
[Music]
that is a great tennis outfit it's
[ __ ] impossible oh [ __ ] I'm not
giving up a face [ __ ]
[Music]
I miss you you say that you don't mean
it okay see I didn't know this tab was
here [ __ ] what is all this holy [ __ ]
this changes everything
whoa oh my god
I'm a Casanova baby Wow oh my god my
best they took this pic in class when I
wasn't looking Oh panty shop so
embarrassing you know the best part
about a casino furry dreams yes
[Music]
I'm shampooing my hair Oh
[Music]
Oh what happens when you have five stars
does your little friend wanna come and
visit me all right
looks like we'll have to in that episode
I'll see you later
it seems like I'm gonna keep playing but
I'm not I promise I'll save for a next
episode say even you don't get that
don't deny my yoga belt Mitch that's